we go all right you've got ten seconds
thanks
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to this evening's virtual meeting of
stratfor union district council's
planning committee
my name is councillor peter richards and
i will be chairing the meeting
for you this evening some housekeeping
to start with if i
may uh please do note this meeting is
being live streamed
and recorded for publication on the
council's website and youtube at a later
date
members will have received the etiquette
for uh virtual meetings in advance of
tonight's meetings we are
fairly well versed but just to reiterate
a few clear
points please make sure your device is
charged or
is charging if you could please mute
your microphones if you haven't done so
already
and remember to unmute them when you're
ready to speak and again if you could
mute them again once you have finished
speaking that would be great
please indicate in the chat bar if you
wish to speak at any stage
um if for please also can you turn off
any phones and other
devices that or at the very least turn
them to silence so that we don't get
disturbed throughout
if for any reason you encounter i.t
issues that cause you to drop out or
leave the meeting for any reason
then please make every effort to rejoin
um
when you do or if you do two numbers
will be put into the meeting chat for
you to call
if you need any help with your i.t if
you can't rejoin and we remain corrupt
the meeting will continue
and you will have been deemed to have
left the meeting at the point at which
you lose
connection with us four members of the
public
um just to make you aware uh we have
conf i can confirm that we have checked
in the presence with
uh legal officer that members can see
and hear all proceedings and they have
confirmed that they have also read and
and understood the update sheet and
the main agenda items we have a number
of officers online with us tonight to
support uh us all um in
first of all from committee services we
have and banks
our legal officer is ross chambers we
have two planners
eddie wrench and victoria captain
uh we are getting some feedback so if we
could please make sure we are all muted
it seems we are now um and last but very
not least
is uh dale barker who is our planning
manager dale do you have a statement you
want to make
yes thank you chairman um i'm planning
manager for this evening my role is to
advise and guide members
members are not bound by any advice or
guidance that officers may give
thank you thank you very much for public
speakers
um please uh if you could dial in
just prior to uh the item that you are
speaking on so that you can observe the
item and then you're ready to go
uh as and when you are called once you
are called if you press start and six on
your keypad
that will unmute your phone and we
should be able to hear you um you will
have noticed we just got some feedback i
think from a live stream
in the background uh of potentially one
of the phones or one of our members
um please could you turn off any live
feeds when you are dialing in uh it does
give us a huge amount of feedback and
actually the live feed is delayed
somewhat
uh from uh from from the meeting itself
uh purely by virtue of the fact that we
have to download it and then re-upload
it and then you can watch it
so please make sure that you are keeping
up with things
on your phones if you are speaking
okay let's dive straight into our main
agenda items first of all apologies and
could you
list the apologies please chairman we've
got apologies from councillors adam
eden jennings and mills
thank you very much councillor adam did
ring yesterday just to
and he asked me to say that uh he's
given his apologies because he is the
ward member and knows uh
five of the six items that we are
speaking on tonight
councillor crump has registered to speak
as the uh joining ward member
and counselor adam has said he has has
nothing further to add other than
uh what councilor crump wants to say and
he's more than happy that councillor
crump
puts across the point he otherwise would
have put um
good okay any disclosures of interest
members
please indicate in the chat if you have
one i'm seeing some shaking heads
doesn't look like anyone's typing okay
no disclosures good minutes are you
happy with the minutes
uh from our last meetings if you are
sorry mr chairman
sorry mr chairman disclosures um
thank you yes i couldn't unmute in time
so that's my fault i do apologize
um i actually mentioned already about
the applications to do with dallas burst
and i'm registered
to speak as the adjacent ward member on
eighteen
zero three one six nine f u al which is
item number four and item number eight
which is
twenty slash zero one three six eight
full so on those two
i will be withdrawing from the debate
okay you will remain on uh
on the committee for the other items at
dallas burst and that you're not
registered to speak on is that correct
yes
that's right lovely okay that's fine
thank you very much
uh minutes then are we happy with all
the minutes i had a lot of thumbs up i'm
going to transfer another thumbs up
yeah we're all good i'll sign those next
time we're in the office good
okay let's move to our first planning
application which is eighteen
zero three one six nine ful dallas burst
and polygrams in southern our presenting
officer is eddie wrench eddie
whenever you are ready it's over to you
thank you chair
uh first off as we've got obviously
several applications at dallas burst and
tonight
i will do a quick overview of the
general site and surroundings and
constraints
and then each individually for each
application i will
bring out more specifics to do with the
actual applications
so first off i'll just give a slight
overview
so dallas piston polo grounds if you if
you didn't know it is uh
just to the west of southam as denoted
here by the black dot
um this is an overview of of the site
from an aerial
hs2 does pass through the main
portion of the site right through the
middle which would be a tunneled feature
exiting just south of the southern road
the main dallas person site is outlined
in the blue line here
um which is built up over time from
around
the early 2000s um
public right of way sm 19 runs in an
east
west uh direction through the center of
the site
as shown uh along here there's also
public right of way sm
24 which is a north south public right
of way to the very eastern of the site
also in the locality is a thorpe roof
which is uh directly abuts much of the
pellet ground
which is in a part of an ancient
woodland and also
just to the other side of the bascot
road
um to the west of the site is long
itched in and often woods
which is a triple sa and ancient
woodland
uh also in the locality is stony thought
paul and barnes
which is a grade 2 listed building
which is donated denoted by the
red coloring here to the site as well
and just give an overview of each of the
applications there is five applications
on tonight
they include the hundred camping
pictures on the western edge of the site
as shown here in blue
the twenty years uh shown with the green
uh to the north of the site the 44
43 bed hotel should i say a full
application which is just to the south
of the years proposal
uh 130 bed outlying proposal
for a hotel which is a in the orange
and finally and a 10 workers apartments
and 10 holiday bedrooms
development shown here in red
now that we've done the overview i'll go
into the first application
um which is for the um
10 staff and 10 overnight accommodation
uh staff accommodation for events
which also has a joining party parking
uh this is a part retrospective
application
as you can see here there was a a
previous
uh barnes as part of which farm part of
the farmland of dallas burst and
which forms part of the where it's being
developed so the building would have the
same footprint
as is proposed there this is the
proposed site plan
so each of the 20 bedrooms would be
identical
would have a small bathroom cooking
and a washing facilities as well as a
single bedroom
that's over two floors and here you can
see also the parking
area which would be to the south of the
building opposite to the agricultural
uses
uh here are some elevations so it is as
i said a
two-story building
with uh detailed pillars and uh tower
clock onto
the very pitch of the roof
uh here's just a close-up again of one
of the rooms on the right hand side as
well as the floor plan for the ground
and first floor
and they are all identical
um it is part retrospective as you can
see here so the basic shell of the
building has been built out now
this is the front which faces northwards
and finally this is a view
looking back towards the building which
is on the right hand side with the
parking which would be to the left-hand
side
and you will notice that obviously hs2
works are obviously ongoing on the site
and that's
you can see that in the background where
the whiteboarding is
um chairman the recommendation
is to grant the application for the
under the conditions and notes on page
18.
there is an update for all the
applications from
long itchington parish council which
details um
just some of their thoughts on the
general development of dallas bursting
and how they would like see a
comprehensive master plan for the site
going forwards
um and that's all for the moment
over to you chair thank you eddie thank
you
very much right let's dive into our
first speakers we have no parish or town
council registered so our first
uh speaker is councillor crump council
crump
hello and welcome thank you mr chairman
um it's relatively
brief and i've got to shuffle between
papers and
spreadsheets and all sorts of different
things so i do apologize if i
slightly stutter or appear even more
distracted than usual
no problem before you start councillor
crump can you bring your microphone
more towards your mouth that's i think
that's going to be better
is that better that's brilliant you
sounded a million miles away but you're
with us very close now we can hear you
loud and clear
you've got three minutes um we'll give
you a 30 second warning whenever you're
ready
far away yeah as is again i've been
speaking with the ward member
quite closely on this uh and understand
the reasons why you can't speak tonight
um certainly i have full sympathy for
lots
uh with dance bursts and not on various
issues uh more particularly the hs2
road position that has caused
significant disruption
um both for satan and also
impact impacted heavily on the dallas
burst and
showgrounds polograms so fully sympathy
and fully sympathized with all the work
uh and disruption
and enjoying this time with coveted as
well we are trying to encourage uh our
businesses
um to keep going so again
they've got a double missile um i fully
appreciate all the hard work they're
doing and
the effect on on the local economy um
and again the the this for the facility
has a lot of potential to benefit
locality and the district as a whole
um we we do appreciate the fact that
um dallas person has the freedoms to do
several things
however five significant applications
are being considered at one times
makes it really clear the need for a
master plan for a site
so large uh to ensure that the extensive
development being proposed can be
considered holistically and again the
problem is
with this one part retrospective so uh
and that always sets alarm vowels with
me irrespective whether it be here or
different parts of the district
um oh sorry i'll just click onto
something else that i was reading
um bear with me two seconds sorry um
through the development of a master plan
including existing and proposed
structures as well as infrastructure and
january's routes
the true impacts of any application
could be measured fairly against
a desired outcome and the likelihood of
success under core strategy
flooding or journeys has been an ongoing
concern of the site given consecutive
development and applications
and development of a plan of further
development with professional assessment
of the impact
each application will have as part of a
whole is required to ensure that the
cumulative impact of these
does not have a detrimental effect on
the area
and neighbouring communities the
approach taken by the applicants
to build significant structures without
permission does fly in the face of
planning policy
and should be actively discouraged this
long with the points made above
that speaks to the lack of respect
played to residents of the area
if the application wants support from
local
community they must better engage to
enshrine the covenant with residents and
businesses that's me mr chairman
hopefully well within the three minutes
you are well done thank you very much
remembers
if you could indicate in the chat please
if you have any questions for councillor
crump
give me a couple of seconds councillor
parry is first councillor parry
thank you chair and good evening
councillor crump um
i hear what you're saying about how
important it is to have a master plan
particularly with the site
as large as this but i would just like
to have
um a bit more of um
valid material planning reasons as to
why
you are objecting to this application
i think it's it's the combination
i'm getting feedback again sorry um um
yeah i think it is cumulative effect and
the fact that things are
done apart retrospectively um i fully
support
the need to um ensure encourage
tourists um and staff accommodation
and things like that but um it's i don't
think going about it the right way
and i think there are concerns the
cumulative effect of all the different
applications
one of which is this will have a
negative impact on on the community
and the drainage system and the
infrastructure um so
that is the main argument behind it um
but like i say
um planning is down to opinions and um
would uh you know if if planning uh
committee's minded to go against it i
would not be offended
that's good to know thank you councillor
crump um no one else has indicated they
wish to ask you a question so thank you
very much for your contribution on this
item right let's move to our
uh agent uh the applicant's agent uh who
is mr peter
frampton mr frampton i believe you've
dialed in if you press star on six
on your keypad that should unmute you we
may be able to hear you
hopefully we'll be able to hear you can
you hear me
we can hello good evening good evening
so i think you know uh you know how uh
this thing these things work uh you've
got three minutes
we'll give you a 30 second warning and
if you could stay online afterwards for
any questions that would be great
otherwise whenever you're ready it's
over to you
thank you chairman in response to
councillor crump it's a matter i will
raise in one of the later items before
you tonight
there is a master plan that has been to
the
regulation committee back in 2009
um so most of the proposals
do actually follow that approved master
plan
but in the context of this proposal and
in considering all of these applications
at the polar grounds this evening
i invite members to pay due regard to a
key message within the national planning
policy framework
and that is that the planning system
must be responsive
to changing economic circumstances in
order to help build a strong and
competitive economy
and indeed in the sites allocation plan
published by the council in october 2020
it states this
the kovid pandemic has had a massive
impact on the local economy
within the district being the fourth
most impacted in the country
diversifying the local economy helping
businesses to grow
and attract new inward investment to the
district will be
critical to ensuring continued
prosperity of the district
surprisingly the changed economic
conditions in this district are not
referred
to in the officers reports before you
the dallas burst and polar grounds is a
major events venue within the district
providing
unrivaled facilities for conferences
celebratory
events large-scale entertainment events
and sports fixtures
like all businesses within the
hospitality sector 2020 has been a cruel
year
the chief planner for the ministry of
housing communities and local government
urged local planning authorities in
march 2020
at the very commencement of the pandemic
to be practical
be pragmatic let's plan for economic
recovery
the land use planning system has a key
role addressing the economic emergency
now faces this country
in supporting new investment that will
bring new jobs
and new sources of revenue to pay for
public services
as restrictions on people movement ease
confidence will return to the
hospitality sector
the quality of the facilities available
at the polar grounds
its geographic location provide the
propensity for this major tourism
facility
to return to being a vibrant and vital
tourism enterprise in the district
spreading as councillor crumb says the
benefits of tourism to the eastern parts
of the district
in managing hotels and providing
excessive service to clients the
fundamental consideration
is the availability of good quality and
reliable staff
the 50 seconds provision of on-site
accommodation is considered essential
in providing suitable accommodation to
support staff working on late shifts
or early morning shifts reducing the
cost of travel
the proposed conditions will safeguard
the accommodation for
employees and for visitors to the person
grounds and i invite your committee to
approve
permission in accordance with the
recommendation thank you
mr frampton thank you very much well uh
well within your time we have a question
for you from councillor parry
councillor parry thank you chair and
good evening mr frampton
um i just wonder whether you can explain
the rationale
why um this has come forward as a
um a retrospective application and
didn't come
uh forward prior to um
the business starting you know just
basically you know thinking that
um they could go ahead and build it i
would just like to
understand the reasons why this has come
to us so late
and if we're having to consider it from
a retrospective perspective
thank you thank you councillor parry
um
it is a matter that i've raised with the
applicant
and expressed to him the risk
that he does face in undertaking
development
in advance of a grant of planning
permission
um he is fully aware of that those risks
uh this application has been with your
authority some time
that's not a criticism of your offices
that's principally being
issued over sorting out drainage main
drainage for
the overall development but
i do not seek to defend the applicant
in him undertaking development in
advance of planning
uh permission uh it does not respect the
planning system and the point councillor
crump
mentioned in terms of giving rise to
concern
to the local community is a fair one of
course in determination
it is the merits of the proposal as it
is presented to you
lovely thank you very much members do
you have any more questions for mr
frampton i'm not seeing anything in the
chat
i'll give you a couple of seconds if you
want to write anything for us
no okay in that case mr frampton thank
you very much i think we're going to
hear from you
a fair bit tonight so um you might want
to stay on the phone
if you want to mute the phone uh if you
press star and six again that will
re-mute your microphone that'd be very
helpful
thank you thanks okay members we have
now a point of clarification from our
officers have
has anyone got a question for our
planning officer
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm not seeing anything at all in which
case let's move to the debate
who would like to kick us off and if you
can indicate in the chat
that would be great councillor parry is
that an indication to
start it is yeah brilliant thank you
thank you
no problem chair um well obviously on
on first first looking at the designs um
in terms of commenting i i have to say
certainly very smart accommodation for
staff
um and and i appreciate it's been a very
difficult year
um and i'm basically trying to look at
this as though
they hadn't started but would we be
looking
to grant it if they hadn't started
because i always think that's a
that's a good basis um i am familiar
with the site
um and of course
the whole business has had a lot of
disruption
and where it's actually located is very
is it is very difficult for members of
staff
um who attend weddings and other big
functions and other big sporting events
um because they're quite a bit way out
of sale them
and the modes of transport is really
quite
challenging and difficult so i can
certainly understand
the need and the rational for
having some staff accommodation because
it does
enable them to do a lot a lot more
events where they can actually bring a
lot more staff
on board and also keep staff on site
so in a nutshell i can't see
any material planning reason to actually
refuse this
so i'm putting forward a proposal to
grant thank you chair
thank you very much that has been
seconded in our chat by councillor
kendall counts kendall do you want to
speak to that
uh i don't think i have anything to add
really i i support what cancer parish
said i think she said everything
okay thank you very much cancer dixon
has indicated second as well but you
beat him to it cancer dixon have you got
anything you want to add at this point
or should we move to a vote move to the
vote chairman good man
okay thank you very much in that case uh
we have a proposal to grant in line with
the officer's recommendation
um and uh considering of course the
update in the update sheet
i will go first councillor richards four
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall four
councillor fleming councillor fleming
for
councillor cron
is oh sorry it's my apologies councillor
curtis
councillor curtis four councillor dixon
councillor dixon four councillor henshaw
seraphin
pennsylvania therapy for
councillor paris councillor paris
councillor parry for
united mr chairman thank you very much
ann uh in that case
committee resolves to grant application
1803 169 ful at dallas person polo
club let's move to our next item which
is
application 1902736 ful
on the same site eddie if you're ready
over to you thank you chair
um so the next application before you is
for
uh the 20 years as shown here where the
green is just
okay so this is a campsite for
construction of 20 years in an arboretum
and sculpture park
setting with associated tracks and hard
surfacing
uh is to the northern uh side of uh
dallas burst and polar grounds adjacent
to
thorpe rough which is directly to the
east as you can just see here on the
aerial view
public right of way sm 19 runs
along the southern border of the site
into the
into the woods
this is the plan outline for the
yurts and arboretum so you can see
details here of the
animal type sculptures and the different
varieties of trees that would be planted
in the setting along with the access
lanes around the site
the yurts would be attached in pairs of
two
um as you can see here as their floor
plans and elevations
uh they would have ensuite two bedrooms
a lounge in a kitchen so
an array of facilities for each one
this is a view from the edge of thorpe
rough
looking westwards towards the fields
so the near field would contain
the yurts again
this one is part retrospective as well
as you can see in part of the field one
of the
units has been built so two of the use
units have been built uh to the rear of
where the
proposed hotel is which you can also see
on the left-hand side of the picture
uh public right-of-way sm19 runs along
that left-hand side of the photo into
the distance
this is a close-up of the yurt building
i
i would stress that it is a building
rather than
a tented yurt so it has uh
foundations and full walls and is a is a
structure in a building in planning
terms
but this one at the moment is just the
one being built
which is the one directly adjacent or
very near to where the hotel is proposed
and chairman the recommendation is to
grant permission for the reasons on
pages 29
and 30 of the agenda uh
the same update again from long engine
and parish council
uh just with their thoughts on on dallas
burstin and how the site moving forward
in terms of a master plan for the site
um and the other update is that uh
originally the description didn't
include
the retrospective nature but this has
obviously been picked up on a recent
site visit
uh over to you chairman thank you eddie
thank you very much
okay uh hopefully our first speaker who
is councillor andrew walster
from stratford uh sorry from southern
town council uh is able to hear us
uh mr uh sorry counselor walster if you
are there if you can press star on six
on your keypad to unmute
for us and you meet your microphone um
and hopefully we'll be able to hear you
good evening mr chairman can you hear me
we can indeed
fabulous welcome uh this evening um we
we uh have allocated three minutes for
you so um
we'll give you a 30 second warning
before your time is up
um whenever you're ready it's over to
you thank you very much mr chairman
hopefully i won't take your three
minutes for a number of points i want to
make for the
committee this evening so i think
southern town council appreciates the
economic arguments that we've heard from
mr hampton already on the previous
application however we do we
also believe that this is not a reason
for unsuitable development within a
rural area
covid will not be the only blocking to
this site in the
uh in the next coming years hs2 will
provide a block as well for a number of
years for the
site to get back on its feet etc
there are a number of points i'd like to
raise in addition to the points that
members have already seen in the town
council's
submission there is no satisfactory
sequential test
on the provision of this or any of the
other accommodation with on-site
the yurts particularly are a permanent
intrusion
into the rural landscape and
particularly for those
people using the the footpath the town
council are considerably concerned about
the total quantum
of um accommodation proposed for the
site across this and a number of other
schemes
and in the town council's view this is
significant over development of a rural
area
the point of strategic planning has
already been raised and the point i
would make
on the response made by mr frampton on
the previous one
is that the 2009 plan is no longer
current and there should be a new
and more up-to-date plan produced for
this site given its significance to
the um to the district the town council
is also concerned that the
level of development proposed across
this and a number of other
applications sets the precedent for the
new village development which has been
proposed by the developer through
consultation with
the town council and the uh and the
district council
sound town council would also agree with
the points made by
my learned friend councillor john venn
at stratfor
longington district council in their
letter of the 15th of
12 20 2020. i'd also
point out to the committee that unlike
the previous application
which the southern town council remained
uh with no comment on
the addition of yurts is not uh in our
view in keeping
with the key uses of the site and
providing accommodation for people
providing
services on the site thank you very much
mr chairman there the points i wanted to
raise on behalf of the attorney council
fabulous council thank you very much
thank you very much
from our members do you have any
questions for
councillor
i'm seeing lots of shaking heads looks
like you've covered all points and all
bases so
uh castle water thank you very much i
see you're registered to speak on um
at least two more of our items so if you
want to press star and six on your
keypad again that should mute you
um and we will speak to you again
shortly no doubt thank you very much
thank you very much okay let's move
again to our applicant's agent who is mr
peter frampton mr frampton again if you
press down on six we should be able to
hear you
can you hear me now chairman we
certainly can welcome back
um uh you have three minutes 30 second
warning whenever you're ready over to
you
thank you chairman a second theme of my
presentations to you
this evening is sustainable rural
tourism
the government policy supports the
growth and expansion of all types of
businesses
in the rural area tourism has the
consequential benefit of supporting
existing businesses businesses in rural
areas where whether local shops
published and smaller scale
event tourism venues this proposal
is in effect a rearrangement of the form
of tourism accommodation
within the extant planning permission
that's 140165 which is referred to in
the
committee report for the campsite at the
polar grounds
and the fundamental objective of the
applicant in the massive
personal investment at the polling
grounds is to ensure that a wide range
of tourist accommodation
is available to suit different tastes
and prices
accommodation in high quality yurts is
particularly sought after
members may be aware of the term
glamping has now entered the lexicon
a form of camping involving
accommodation and facilities more
luxurious than those
associated with traditional camping that
is precisely what these yurts are
providing substantially enhanced
accommodation to that provided in some
years with
loose mats on the ground and no inside
sanitary facilities
the proposed arboretum setting will
further enhance
these years as tourist accommodation in
terms of the comments made by the
previous speaker
he made reference to a sequential test
clearly policy on sequential tests is to
provide
guidelines not tram lines and there will
be no purpose in looking for sites in
southern
urban area or stratford upon avon for a
location to yurts which are associated
with this
polar grounds and the events venues
which are located here
secondly in terms of the fear of
precedent precedent relies on all fours
and the consent granted here tonight
could not be used
as a precedent for a major housing
development which is not being
pursued at this present point in time
and has no status whatsoever
thank you chairman mr fountain wonderful
thank you very much members do we have
any questions for our agent
please if you can indicate in the chat
if you do counselor dixon has a question
for you councilor dixon thank you
chairman mr frampton um
the officer showed us uh pictures of uh
of a yurt being being constructed
um also we now have papers there is a
description of that construction
now i could either wait for the officer
to
pose a question to him but i'm sure you
are fully aware of the uh
the nature of these yurts um and i'll
read the report it says the proposed
yurts
would be fairly substantial in
construction concrete-based
insulated steel framed walls draped in
white
canvas and my dictionary described the
yurt
as a circular tent
of felt or skins uh
are they uh draped in
canvas or are they indeed what appeared
on that photograph to be block walls
uh cancer they are draped in canvas
over walls to provide the
insulation and quality of accommodation
that is being provided so they're not
the sort of flappy canvas
type yurt that you you may see
that sit on the ground with i said with
mats on them
they are very much an enhanced a
glamping style
where you've got a solid floor that
gives insulation
solid floor to the walls and then
fixtures
in terms of inside sanitation and in
fact they have been designed
bespoke for dallas burst and
at this site i would describe them as
round
houses but never mind right okay thank
you councillor dixon
councillor parry has a question for you
harry
thank you chair normally in fact tony
councillor dixon stole my thunder
because i was going to ask
exactly the same point so well done for
getting ahead of me on this occasion
council dixon i have no further
questions thank you
okay um does anyone else have any if
they can indicate in the chat
i think councillor curtis has his hand
up so i'm going to ask him to come in
now
um just a question on the planting in
the arboretum
and it from the outline sketches
it looks i would say rather artificial
and i just wonder if that planting
scheme and
general planting in the whole area is
taking
into account climate change and what
type of trees are planned for the area
well for operating
thank you thank you kelsey i mean just
reviewing the draft conditions uh it
seems to me it would be appropriate to
have a
tree planting condition so that the
types of trees and the
density of the trees can be provided to
you and considered as a matter of
detail pursuant to a planning condition
there are various trees that have a
high urban quality for extracting carbon
some of those could be put there
they would be indigenous trees rather
than exotic trees
but i do think if members are minded to
grant
permission there ought to be a a
landscaping scheme
condition imposed on a grant of
permission
thank you that's very helpful thank you
chair lovely thank you very much and
councillor fleming
please council fleming okay thank you
chair
um as we've seen the walls are made of
concrete blocks and the steel frame and
the roof what is the roof construction
going to be
and because we haven't obviously got
plans to check so what what's the
construction of the roof on top of those
metal
frames i think i'm right
the council is timber boarding and then
the canvas over the top
right okay so effectively
you can build a bungalow and put a sheet
over it and call it a yurt is that
basically
what this is going to be well i think
years has no statutory definition it
seems to me in terms of its
form and shape it is a
high quality yurt a condition will
restrict its use so it's not
permanent accommodation it is a form
of tourism accommodation if you are
seeking a sort of
a an earthy yurt as i've described
earlier this is not for you but if
you're looking for
accommodation in a yurt-style
structure that provides good standard of
amenities
then i would suggest this is the form of
accommodation that you would seek
okay thank you lovely thank you very
much everyone um that appears to
conclude the questions for you mr
franklin so thank you very much again if
you want to press star on six to mute
and we'll speak to again in about 15-20
minutes good okay uh let's move to
officer we have no ward members i've
alluded to earlier so let's move to
uh points clarification with our
officers do we have any questions for
our officers
a couple of seconds to indicate in the
chat
no um i'll ask a quick one about the
tree planting if i may eddie um have you
any indication as to what
uh breeds of tree and and scale of tree
planting is going to be
put in um and what consideration did you
give to including a
a condition uh for the landscaping
detail
um there is broad uh overview of what
type of planting so
they have got various feature trees
specimen
conifers and evergreen trees but they're
you know there isn't uh a detailed plan
uh beyond what is the uh
type of trees that they've shown round
the edge of the
submitted plan that we saw it's
certainly worth
i think if we've got any concerns about
the type of trees or impact they may
have
then i certainly would recommend a
condition
so i think if members are minded then
yeah certainly that's a way to go down a
detailed landscaping condition
uh which can be reviewed by our
landscape officer in terms of
their local benefit and indigenous
species i think
okay you you'll find that that is
appropriate um
an appropriate an enforceable condition
given the conversation we've had
i would yes yeah yeah lovely um
two councillors indicated questions
first of all i'm going to come to
councillor curtis because i'm presuming
that your question may have been on the
same lines
um no actually uh it wasn't chair but
it was a point of clarification really
from the officers um
do the do the materials used in
constructing
these buildings whatever we call them
have any bearing on whether they would
be granted planning permission or not
because i think taking out the council's
points really what we are looking at
are breeze block bungalows um
if if they weren't called yurts
would it have any so does that have any
is there any material consideration
there at all
i think in planning terms rather than
necessarily the materials
the difference is that for a year
or a tenth uh we'd be looking at the
change of use of
land as they're not put they're not
classified as actual buildings you know
they're removable structures
where in whereas in in this case they're
considered to be development
and they come into the description of a
built development in their planning law
so really rather than necessarily the
materials it comes down to whether it's
a building or
not um officers have assessed it as a as
a building
almost uh irrespective of what it's
called
um they would be in the planning law
they're considered to be buildings with
foundations and and walls so the main
difference is yeah
rather than a camping site which would
be for
a number of pitches as we'll see later
and the change of use of land
then this is for actually 20 buildings
for overnight accommodation so that the
planning consideration comes into the
fact that they are
buildings and permanent structures
that's great thank you very much
thank you very much and councillor dixon
please uh thank you chairman
uh eddie has just uh answered the
question i was about to pose
oh perfect lovely stuff okay um i can
see no one else asking questions for
uh clarification points so let's move
into the debate
who is going to kick us off
don't all jump at once councillor parry
is there first
castle parry
thank you chair i thought i'd better
dive in as it seemed a little bit a
little bit quiet
um this is quite an interesting
application because obviously
there was the um previous grant
on having um a mix of yurts and
tents and camping things but um
to me the underlying uh
reason that we should be granting this
comes back to our policy cs24
which is on tourism and leisure
development
and that particularly i think in liked
of
covid and also as a district
um 40 percent of our economy is actually
driven
by the hospitality and tourism business
so i think
you know we have a niche in
stratford-on-avon district
for tourism and leisure we have a policy
cs24 um and whilst i think we can have
various discrepancies over the type of
the materials
essentially um you know we should be
supporting um i think we should be
supporting
a business venture that capitalizes
on our one of our big strengths
in the district so i would be very happy
to propose grant on this
with the exception on the um
the um condition on the landscaping with
regard to the trees
i would like it that it should they
should be mature trees
we have so many developments come
forward and they just put little
saplings in that take
sort of five to ten years to grow and i
think if this is a quality
it's being positioned very much as an a
quality
upmarket uh glamping initiative
but any tree in landscaping we should
have really serious
mature trees that that have longevity
um and don't suddenly die or at least if
there's a clause there that if any of
the
the plantate the planting um withers
there is a replacement um clause in that
as well
but i'm happy to get to go ahead and
propose grant on this
thank you fabulous thank you very much
councillor parry before we move to
our other speakers i just want to get
clarification from
uh from our planning officer that they
understood
the additional condition that you wanted
and put in and you're happy to have word
something to the effect uh that and
the councilor parry has just stated yeah
so it would be the landscaping condition
um
we would probably be the standard
landscaping condition but we can
certainly attach a note as well
saying that we would be looking for
mature species
um throughout the site so a mature stock
of trees
and we can add a condition about
replacement planting within the
five-year period as well
okay in that so that's two separate
conditions one for a landscaping scheme
with an a note about mature trees and
then a second condition
for replacement of uh trees should they
die within a five-year period
if that's one i would advise yes perfect
right
council power you're happy with that
brilliant i think that's a thumbs up for
anyone that can't see councillor parry
um okay let's move to our next speakers
now i can see council
fleming has indicated he has a question
is that a question for the officers or
are you uh contributing to debate at
this point council planning
uh contributing to the debate really
okay in that case if you don't mind i'm
going to go in order of
of speakers that have indicated um casa
kendall is next cancer candle
thank you chairman as as before very
little to add to what councilor paris
said she said everything
that i would say i fully agree with that
both the two conditions
she suggested i don't have a problem
with these
yurts even the materials are a bit
different to what you'd usually expect i
think they look like fantastic little
units and i think they'll be
very very useful going forward out of
covets so i'm happy to second their
proposal
fantastic thank you very much cancer
kendall uh councillor curtis please
yeah thank you chair um i absolutely
take uh councillor paris points about
the you know 40
of the economy we are incredibly reliant
on
tourism and thank you council perry for
raising the
in the or extending the point about the
trees
i just have a i i do have some sympathy
with councillor wolfson from
i think it was southern town council um
and i it it does make me feel uneasy
that there are so many of these
applications that have come before us
that are retrospective um and
i yes i i have sympathy with
with his point that we really need to
see
the overall plan sort of master plan of
this uh
we've been told that there was a master
plan approved back in 2009
but i i just feel a little unease with
the way this has been presented to us
thank you understood thank you
councillor curtis i was going to wait
until the end
uh to say this but i'll say it now given
you've raised it with a master plan
um i think that's rather than something
that the committee should be focusing
its mind on
that is something that's more of a
policy uh issue and that should be taken
up
by um the relevant portfolio holder
uh and the relevant portfolio holders
should be addressed by
interested parties but particularly ward
members so really i think it's for
councillor crump and
councillor adam to liaise with uh the
portfolio holder and find an appropriate
way forward for a master plan it's not
really within our gift sadly
um okay councillor fleming is next
please
yeah really i i sort of agree with
councillor parry and
subsequent speakers in terms of uh how
we should be moving on with uh
with the tourism and and promoting what
we can
one big worry is if we grant
keep grant in retrospective does that
give the
the developer a green light to build
what he likes then come for the
permission afterwards
for the next three projects he's got on
this list tonight
we have to be a little bit careful that
you know that we don't
run away with the idea that he can build
what he likes and come and see us later
on
and we'll give him a green light to
carry on that's all that's just a point
i'd like to make
understood um i i share and i've said
this many times before
um i share your frustration in the
public frustration with retrospective
planning applications
it does irritate me immensely that uh
people operate outside of the planning
framework but we do have a planning
framework and it does allow for
retrospective planning applications so
we must view
this and any future applications on its
own individual merits as if it were
being presented for the first time
regardless of where the building has
started
um certainly we have refused
applications that have
already begun work or have completed
work
and that those buildings those
applications have had to be taken down
again
so rest assured it's not a simple
question of let's start building and
we'll get a permission
um the the council are quite strict on
that they're very clear they follow the
the
the law and the guidelines so i just
thought i'd make that point now
um we do have a proposal and we have a
second debt to
grant uh in line with the officer's
recommendation and uh with the details
on the update
sheet uh there being no further uh
indications of anyone wishing to speak
let's move to a vote i will start
councillor richards
four thank you councillor kendall
councillor kendall four thank you
councillor fleming
councillor fleming four thank you
councillor crump
that's the crown pop stein
councillor curtis
councillor curtis four
councillor dixon castle dixon four
councillor henshaw seraphin um
on this one i'm a bit concerned about
conservative perspective
so olive stein on this one thank you
thank you councillor parry harry
councillor parry four that's six four
two abstentions chen
marvelous thank you very much and
therefore committee resolves to grant
application 1902 736 ful dallas person
polo grounds in southern moving straight
on to our
next item which is nineteen zero two
zero zero nine ful
at dallas burst and polar grounds in
southern eddie is once again our
presenting officer eddie when you're
ready
over to you thank you chair
uh next up is a full application
for the 43 bed hotel which is shown here
in yellow
so is a 40 43 bedroom hotel
with a restaurant and spa facilities and
some associated car parking space
is part retrospective again with the
main
body of the building having been
constructed
this is just to the south of the
previous years
application which you just heard and to
the south of sm19 the public right of
way
as you can just see here thought rough
is just to the
northeast of the site as well
this is the layout for the proposed
hotel
with the restaurant wing to the eastern
side and spa facilities to the
west it's quite landscaped gardens
similar again to the
arboretum for the years so we'd follow
on
a lot of those motifs uh
these are the proposed elevations
so at the moment the main central body
framework has been constructed
and you can see here that the two
extensions to the east and west for the
restaurant the spa
would would uh spout off from those
elements
uh it would be uh two and a half stories
this is just a snapshot of a part of the
floor
ground floor plan showing the spa area
which would have a solarium uh sauna
and pool outdoor pools
this is the uh eastern wing which is for
the restaurant
uh type area with a number of
uh seating plants uh
this is some 3d visualizations and an
elevation
of the uh spa wing
there's obviously roman type uh
architectural details of pillars and
and details these are some
computerized artists interpretations of
some of the internal views of the spa
this is a
of the building
you still wear this eddie oh i'm i'm
back now i don't know what happened
there
temporarily glitched but you're okay
please don't just kick me out of my
presentation but i'll just open it again
um
sorry it's just taking a moment to load
the joys of modern technology to take as
much time as you need eddie
that's right thanks it usually works
fine i don't know what's tonight
having a don't worry having a moment
uh right let me get back to where i was
i'm not quite sure where it cut out but
i'll start from the
elevations again so these are the
proposed elevations for the 43 bed hotel
with the main hotel element and
centrally located
and the restaurant and spa wings to the
east and west respectively
this is the floor plan for the spa with
steam and sauna rooms and outdoor pools
this is the floor plan for the
restaurant which is uh to the eastern
side of the main hotel
these are some elevations and artist
impressions of this spa building
again some artist impressions uh
computerized
from the internal aspects of the spa
here is a a picture of the
main hotel building as it is today so
this is looking from
the south looking northwards towards a
building
this is a closer view so you can see the
main details of the hotel element with
the
restaurant would come just to the right
of where the picture is now
this is the rear of the building from uh
the public right-of-way
sm19 um so the yurts field would be just
behind us and the
path runs left to right here
uh and chairman the recommendation
is to grant for the uh
conditions and notes on page 40 and 41
of the agenda
uh again i won't go to details of uh
long ancient and parish councils uh
update in the sheet but
suffice to say that it's that it's the
same reasons again in terms of a site
master plan and
some of the retrospective nature of the
applications on site
um and that's all chair over to you
thank you
eddie thank you very much okay let's go
to our speakers we have no perishing
town council
uh listed so we'll go to um our
objectives who is councillor
uh walster again from southern town
council council wallster
again if you press star on six and we
should be able to hear you straight away
good evening chairman again i hope you
can hear me again we can welcome back
uh i think you know the drill by now
three minutes thirty second warning
whenever you're ready it's over to you
i will do my best without wanting to
repeat myself to the um
committee there are a number of points
i'm going to make across all three
applications this evening
on the two particular ones that concern
hotels the town council has
significant concerns on visual harm to
the
local area and the fact this particular
application is part retrospective
members can see the visual harm has in
fact already taken place
the site already has significant light
pollution
areas the area between southern and
basket heath has traditionally been
a dark sky area this is no longer the
case with the introduction of the
um of the polo ground some of the points
i'd like to make as well as we
uh for the committee to consider
is that the eastern part of the stratfor
borough is not predominantly based upon
income from tourism it's predominantly
based upon income from manufacturing
and from engineering and looks to towns
to the east north and
south of the uh uh sound of southern for
its uh
for its income um the uh
point uh raised on the last one is also
pertinent to this which is that no
sequential test or no suitable
sequential test has been done
suitable sites for the provision of a
hotel have become available in
sale them within the last two years or
within
land that is within the town boundary
but on the outskirts of the town
the overall quantum of the development
that you are being asked to consider
across the applications tonight we still
believe
is still high for rural um for a rural
setting
to put that into context this
application alone is equivalent to
building mallory court
just outside of southern and um the
total quantum is 403
which would be nine times mallory court
or three and a half times the size of
kumabi
um we also still believe although i take
the point mr hampton made in his last
one that this does set a precedent
for a new village which is which has
been consulted upon
within this area and we would ask
respectfully the committee to refuse
this application
thank you uh councilor walter thank you
very much
if you bear with us while i seek
questions from our members members do we
have any questions
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm seeing very little movement either
everyone's frozen or they
no one has a question looks like no
questions so uh
counselor thank you again um if you want
to press star on six because we will
hear you from you again in about 15
minutes
uh that will be great thank you okay
um to our applicant's agent again mr
frampton
uh star and sixth if you would please
thank you chairman marvelous we've got
your three minutes 30 second warning
whenever you're ready thank you um
in respect to the next item i item seven
i will have a
submission to make to the committee
regarding the updated master plan
but turning to this proposal the
principal hospitality venue at the polar
ground is known as the ixl center
this venue has a capacity for 750 guests
in a banqueting style seating
arrangement
and an 800 capacity and a theatre style
arrangement
the venue is very attractive within the
business tourism sector
as it provides versatile and
multi-purpose space including the
ability to allow vehicles
to be driven into the main auditorium
for vehicle
model launches which has already
occurred and reflects the central
location of this facility in the
midlands
therefore being a suitable exhibition
space for manufacturers
presently there is a marketing
constraint at the polar grounds which
results in a significant loss of
potential business
namely the absence of on-site overnight
accommodation
not all everybody is going to stop
staying a year
the lack of on-site accommodation
impacts upon both business
and leisure tourist sectors the
requirements for patrons to leave the
polar grounds and return the next day is
not efficient for many business
functions
and raises corporate social
responsibility issues
and i note the comment about sites
potentially in southern
but it is the locational synergy uh
between
overnight accommodation and the venues
that are
at the polar grounds that makes the
hotel accommodation and
the larger hotel proposal work it would
not work if it's in an off-site
location furthermore providing
on-site overnight accommodation avoids
unnecessary trip movements taking place
because of people leaving
and returning the next day
this is a proposal for a small boutique
style hotel with spa facilities uh
in my submission this proposal is an
important component of the hospitality
offer at the polar grounds
and i hope that members will support the
granting of planning permission
and i for the reasons i've already said
i regret
this comes to you in part retrospective
form it did start out life
as a building that had got a planning
permission but i acknowledge readily
that the applicant has adapted that
structure
contrary to that permission but as
councillor perry says
the merits should be seen on the basis
of the plans
not on the existence of the building as
it stands today
thank you chairman mr frampton thank you
very much we do have a question from
councillor harry
councillor hello mr frampton again and
good evening
um i just wonder whether you can just
give some explanation
as to um the lapsed
planning applications that were granted
for the hotel
um there was an outline planning
commission and there was a vary
and why why it's lapsed and is
what we're seeing at the moment am i
right in thinking it's on the same site
as the previous
permissions were granted if you could
just give some clarification on that
please thank you
yes certainly the original original
outline planning permission was for a
140 bed
hotel um the location
of that it is close to the home
farm eddie showed a plan uh
with the very weather the staff and
visitor accommodation
is the car parking required
for that hotel development
is involved in the hs2 land
so that couldn't go ahead uh because of
hs2 but also
at that time a 140 bed hotel is a
substantial hotel
and the applicant wished to provide some
overnight accommodation and hence
has pursued this application for a
smaller hotel
there is a second application for a much
bigger hotel
but the cost of these developments is
such that
he needed to pursue a smaller hotel
first before the bigger hotel
but that's the reason why that original
one didn't go ahead because of hs2
and the consultation zone and the land
taken for the works
lovely thank you very much members we've
got any more questions for mr frampton
at this point
i'm seeing very little activity so i'm
going to assume no in that case mr
frampton if you could press star on six
again and we'll hear you
hear from you on the next item but thank
you again
okay uh points of clarification for our
officers does anyone have a question
for eddie on this item
counselor dixon whenever you're ready
counselor thank you chairman
um on page 38 eddie we refer to
column lighting would be installed along
the access road
now i wonder in actual fact does this
need to be
at a height or could actually what i
would describe as bollards
provide the necessary illumination to
keep motorists
on the right route to the hotel given
the
rural nature rather than have what i
would call
lamp posts and i note that there isn't a
landscaping
condition within the recommendations uh
for this item and having seen what i
would only regard as a hideous
rear facade to the um to the
hotel or the proposed hotel obviously
the view from both the yurts
obviously second-class citizens
occupying those with that view of the
hotel
and walkers along that public right of
way uh will have
not what i would describe as a very uh
pleasant outlook of that rear black
hotel do we have any landscaping
opportunities to uh to hide it
there is some opportunity i think um
within the site plan um obviously part
of the element
is uh a rare extension almost that
protrudes right up against
the uh public right of way i'll just
share a plan actually i think it might
be
in terms of the floor area um
so there is some elements that we could
do a more detailed uh landscaping plan
they have got some details of trees more
in this area so there would be some
uh trees and flower beds wildflower beds
towards the northern aspect which would
some go somewhat to hide in the building
but there would be
definite harm from that public right of
way in terms of views
as well as obviously the yurts but there
is opportunity to
to adapt that um but yeah there is some
various plants of uh standard stock i
think they're looking at mainly in terms
of that
area but this is a much more formal type
garden
um than uh than a normal landscaping
plan it would be
more for walking and uh sitting out
rather than a general
uh mitigation i would say in terms of
the lighting
um there you go
so the main lighting is yeah around
where the proposed car park is and along
the access
it was adapted uh slightly because there
was issues with the
pond and some of the ecological issues
so some of the lighting has been taken
away there
at the moment we can only really go by
what the applicant
has applied for in terms of in terms of
lighting but if members felt that uh
something
less or low-key would be preferential we
could do a
notwithstanding condition in terms of
the lighting and look to
secure a different measures for lighting
uh particularly along the access road
um so that is a is an option as well
um so yeah and those two elements so
there could be a condition
um relating to both those measures if
members felt that it was necessary in
those cases
thank you eddie probably thank you very
much eddie we also have a
question from councillor parry please
thank you chair um i was also going to
ask about
the the landscaping and again i think
if we were minded to if we were minded
to grant
then a condition on the maturity of the
trees i think is absolutely essential
um the other point i just wanted to make
um
i know um this has come forward as a
retrospective
application but it it it appears to me
to be really very very very advanced in
its construction
and i just wondered has this application
come forward
as a result of you know enforcement
taking um action on it because it just
i'm just surprised that a building of
this scale and size
um has come about unnoticed
uh enforcement for a long time so they
do uh keep quite a close
eye on a lot of dallas burst and
um because of the retrospective nature i
think of
of various applications on site so is
one
they're monitoring and have been for a
significant time
um it was it was first constructed i
think several years ago now
in quite a detail and then was held up
in terms of making a decision
partly because the plans were adapted on
several occasions
and there was also to do with the
drainage
and objections from the environment
agency which took a long time to secure
in terms of connecting up to the main
sewer so there has been a long delay in
those
um but it is one that partly done by
enforcement i think they must have known
as soon as it was probably went up but
they
they tended to carry on i think whilst
the application was in
uh being determined which has been quite
a few uh
quite a long time now but it is
it's been substantially completed
certainly
okay thank you very much eddie um we
have uh one final question for you from
councillor henshaw seraphin please
counselor
you are muted at the moment councillor
seraphin so you will need to unmute
i do apologize thank you chair all right
um
there seems to be a lot of retrospective
on this site
uh as though it's taking no notice of
planning applications
are you supposed to do it properly um
the other thing is the rear of this
building
it just looks like well is there
anything eddie
that we could do in the conditions to
alter the rear of that building
i mean the front looks attractive but
the rear
looks just like barnes
it does spoil the visual impact
certainly let me just see what is
i'll just double check to see what the
actual finished
um require what is the proposed finish
because i'm not 100 certain because of
the respective nature of it
it's hard to tell some bits whether
they're the finished element or whether
it's going to be
recladding something else but i will
just double check
cherry if i may while eddie's doing that
member i would ask members to consider
if they're uncomfortable with the
materials used at the rear i would ask
them to consider deferring the
application
so that we can achieve a measure of
agreement with the applicant
rather than trying to do this by by
condition um but that it
is a little bit dependent on on what uh
eddie finds when he does his research
it does say so in terms of what they've
highlighted in their thing in their
application form sorry it does say
rendered walls with stone detailing
so what is shown i would assume is going
needed to be would need to be rendered
and things to align
with the details of uh the application
form and we could
uh in terms of that materials condition
i think that's already attached
uh condition two we could make sure that
it's in
accordance with the application form in
terms of having that rendered wall so
then you would have a similar finish
uh more to the front uh
the front and sides of the building as
stands so yeah we can certainly word
that condition to
be in accordance with the application
form yeah
also yeah i agree with councillor parry
about mature trees um
we're in the landscape area because
because it is a large building and it
does stand out
it does need a bit of blending in i
think
okay thank you thank you thank you very
much
um there are no questions uh in the chat
for
further clarification so let's counselor
dixon has come in with a
late question councillor dixon obviously
sorry chairman it was just that uh
eddie just mentioned that uh having
looked at that he simply said
that we could then ensure that the front
and the sides are
it was the rear facade which i hate and
i think that was the one that most
people had objection to
is it covering rear elevation which is
totally black eddie
no sorry i meant to say that um that the
rear
is if it's done by the what they've put
in forward in their application form in
terms of rendered walls
it would have a similar appearance to
how the front and sides look at the
moment
so if i share a picture i think they've
done some work to the front and sides
as you can see here so i would expect
that to be carried on
to the rear basically of the element
that we're talking about
thank you ernie i i obviously
misunderstood that you were
obviously meaning that the back would be
done the same as the front yeah
yeah sorry i probably wasn't clear thank
you thanks
okay lovely thank you very much let's
now move into our debate who would like
to kick us off
if indeed anyone would like to kick us
off
i'm i'm looking at hands moving and
people typing but nothing's got ah here
we go councillor dixon is first in
council dixon
let's get us cracking thank you chairman
i'm gonna say essentially when i read
the report i thought myself well this
uh seemed a reasonable request
and certainly having seen those pictures
the areas which i do
focus on without a doubt are the needs
for good landscaping to
hide as much of that rear elevation
unless of course it does indeed
blend with the rest if that happens
that's fine
however i would not wish to see what i
would describe as
lamppost along the length of that
driveway and i would like to see
low-level lighting and if that can be
either part of one of the conditions or
taken on as a note
to see if that can be accommodated uh i
would certainly then support
the application lovely thank you
very much um i would say at this point
and
and for you to consider and other
members consider we do have a condition
number 11 approved lighting scheme only
we could add in a note to the effect
that you've just said
about um uh lampposts or
low level lighting rather than posts
okay that's the
kendall is next on my list cancer
campbell
thank you chairman um yeah i i've got no
concerns with this uh
i agree with councillor dixon if i i'd
prefer to see that lighting to be the
bollards
sort of lighting i think that's a good
point so i'd support that as it can
as a note added to the condition on
lighting um
other than that i think it's a nice
little hotel i'm happy to propose
that we approve that we grant the
application
marvelous thank you very much council
kendall just to confirm uh there was
discussion about the materials condition
which i think is conditioned to
uh to be in line with the application
form
and plans you're presumably happy that
that is the wording
yeah i'm fine with that yes i i think
that's yeah i think that's what's going
to happen anyway
i think that's what should happen anyway
but yeah i completely agree okay good
councillor parry's next
thank you chair um i mean i do have cons
my concerns relate back
to the fact how much this is being
developed and
we're here yet again from a
retrospective perspective
um i'm not really i don't feel
particularly comfortable
with the rear of the building um because
i'm not seeing any real
i would like to have seen some
architectural designs
as to what the rear of the building
looked as a finished
item um and i'm just struggling
to whilst i don't actually have a
problem with the principle of this
but i just wonder whether there's any um
in in terms of the conditions that the
the office is really
i'm just concerned about the finished
item at the back and i just don't feel
that we've got
sufficient information and plans in
front of us
and i would rather actually see this be
deferred and come back
with some proper designs and schemes
that i can really get my head around
i just feel um i feel
i feel i'm being pushed towards granting
when i haven't got all of the
information particularly in respect to
the rear of the building
right in front of me i would like to see
architectural plans
in front of me so i could see exactly
i'm not comfortable i know exactly what
the rear of this building is going to be
i think the front looks great i think
the concept is fine
but i just feel i'm being pushed down a
route
to grant when i haven't got all the
facts in front of me
um and i don't know what other members
think
okay thank you very much councillor
parry
did you beat yourself cancer just for a
moment
thank you very much um what what i'll do
eddie if you could bring up
any images uh that you have particularly
uh for the back of the rear of the
building
um just while we carry on now while you
do that if you could cycle them on the
screen so
members can see uh and we will bring in
our other speakers just to make sure
that we um
um is that the elevations or the actual
plans as it's built
so councillor parry is wanting to see
and fully understand
the architectural designs of the
building both
front sides and in particular
rear yeah so i've got that one up here
now so they
you should be able to see the top of is
the front elevation
which is the one uh which would face
southwards
and then the one towards the yurts and
the public right of way
is the central elevation here so it's a
it's a planar elevation with windows
with windows with with less detailing
should i say but it would be in the same
materials as the front elevation as
shown it's obviously quite difficult
when they part build
elements but there's nothing to define
the difference so i would expect
the front and rear in terms of materials
would be
identical it would just be down to the
details which would be a simpler
rear i'm elevation
thank you very much i can see councillor
parry putting two thumbs up for that one
so i think we've
we've covered offer the concerns she had
um counselor curtis is next on my list
counselor curtis
thank you sure yeah um i echo very much
counselor paris point
i feel we're being bumped into this in
many respects
and i'm also concerned i mean eddie uh
you
you wrote down that there is definite
harm
from the public right of way and it does
concern me that not only does the
building as it
currently stands it looks more like an
industrial unit
than a hotel um why did it have to be
built
so close to the footpath um
it's not on this site there is not a
shortage of land available
um and that that really concerns me as
well
and just looking at the rear of the
building
um it it's to me i'm not a builder sorry
but it seems odd to complete a building
in that sort of metal cladding which it
looks like
and and then to to face it with
some type of brick finish that seems
unusual i don't know
thank you thank you councillor curtis
council for dixon next please
thank you chairman i'm gonna say
councillor kendall i think proposed uh
proposed uh grant on this one and i'm
happy to second that
uh with those uh comments regarding the
uh the lighting and the materials etc
marvelous thank you very much um i've
seen no one else indicating in the chat
that they wish to make a contribution to
the debate at this
point i'm gonna give you a couple of
seconds if you wish to make any further
comment
before we move to a vote jerry if i may
i have three changes that i think i've
picked up from members
the lighting the rear materials and
a landscaping scheme some planting
that's my understanding too yeah
excellent thank you
council curtis has come back for another
comment to council curtis
yes if councillor perry wanted to put
forward a proposal to
defer i would be very happy to second
that
you are well within your rights to
propose deferral
on your own if you like and i'm sure if
council perry wanted a second she would
i would propose deferring until we have
further relevant information or all the
relevant information
okay thank you very much um i will seek
a second
for that now we do have a proposed uh
proposal that has been seconded
already so we'll have to hear that first
council power has indeed seconded
your proposal councillor curtis so uh if
the first proposal
fails then we will come to yours as our
second proposal
let's look to the first proposal first
so that proposal is to grant in line
with the officer's
recommendation with the addition of the
note
the materials condition and landscaping
condition
i will go first councillor richards four
thank you councillor kendall
councillor kendall four cue councillor
fleming
cancer fleming four
and silicon council chrome pop stein
councillor curtis councillor curtis
against
councillor dixon councilman
paul councillor henshaws
council against against
okay that's four four
three against and one abstention
sorry and uh you you this my computer
glitch slightly there did you say that
was
four four three against with one
abstention is that correct
correct marvelous thank you very much in
that case
uh the committee resolves to grant
application nineteen
zero two zero zero nine f u l that's
dallas person programs and
sell them good okay let's move to our
next item which is sixteen two zero one
sorry zero two one four seven ful
dallas person polar grounds in southern
uh eddie is our presenting officer eddie
over to you
thank you chair um so the next
application up is for the 130 bed hotel
which is the orange site here
is an outline application uh for the
direction of 130 bed hotel
with a car parking uh we can't see it
oh sorry
sorry thank you yeah that's working now
thanks eddie thank you dale
no problem so this is uh the orange site
it's the outline for a 130 bed hotel
with a car parking uh
via vehicular access from the a45
a cycle way and enabling works
it is for access and principle with
appearance landscaping layout and scale
uh reserved for later
uh as i said all details are indicative
sorry uh are indicative at the moment
but this is the general
uh site area and footprint of the likely
look of the hotel so this is the
indicative place
uh again this is an indicative floor
plan um
which is likely to be over three floors
um you can see the central a2 atrium and
entrance with the
uh hotel rooms around the outside
this is a photo from the car park to the
west of the proposed site
the proposed hotel would sit between
just to the other side of the fence here
span the length of that field
again it's looking southwards so the
proposed hotel would sit just to the
left of these trees the length of that
field
and finally this is looking from the car
park associated
um with the hotel this is looking uh
westwards towards um southam in the
background
and so you get an idea of the topography
and outlook from that you would get from
the hotel
chairman the recommendation
is to refuse the application for the
four reasons
on pages 54 and 55 of
the agenda updates again from long each
term
parish council which we've gone through
already
and that's all thank you chair over to
you
eddie thank you very much um once again
we have no parish town council uh
listed as a speaker so we'll move
straight to our objective
who is councillor walster from southern
town council
council wallston welcome back uh star on
six if you wouldn't mind to
unmute yourself
can you hear me we can indeed fabulous
welcome back
so three minutes 30 second warning
whenever you're ready
thank you very much good evening
everybody again um a number of points
um to raise again some of these you'll
have heard already on the
preceding applications but yet again i
raised the point of the sequential test
not being met
on this application and the suitable
sites have been available in the town
and the surrounding area for the uh for
the
um this type of development
um we're also concerned about the
precedent again
development sets within the um
boundary or substrate adjacent to the
boundary of the town of southam and
again i would raise the
point of total quantum which you've
already heard me uh
raise i would also draw members
attention to our original
um objections which include
the excessive light pollution and as you
have seen from the
pictures already put up by your officer
high level lighting already exists on
this site to an extensive amount
and is visible from longington on the
coventry road as you drive down
with an evening and again i think most
of the points i've raised on the
previous application so i won't bore you
with them again
but we would support your office's
recommendation to refuse
this application for the reasons that he
has stated
thank you wonderful thank you very much
members do we have any questions for
councillor worldstar please
i'm seeing lots of shaking heads
it looks like you've covered all bases
once again counsellor so thank you very
much this is the last time we're going
to hear from you this evening i think so
thank you for your contribution and
patience throughout all of these
applications at this point you're
probably best served to continue
watching on the live stream
through either youtube or on our website
um so
you are able now to hang up your phone
but thank you again for your
contributions
thank you very much thanks
okay in that case we moved now to our
applicant's agent again mr frampton
mr frampton if you pressed on six i'm
sure we'll be able to hear you any
second
can you hear me challenge we can indeed
welcome back
once again three minutes 30 second
warning over to you
thank you the 43 bedroom hotel will only
meet part of the
hotel accommodation requirement from the
five venues at the polar ground these
comprise the ixl center which i've
referred to
the clubhouse the millstone here the
cloud pavilion
and the golden jubilee and the
investment strategy that's
been undertaken is to enable several
events to be held concurrently
so making efficient use of the capital
assets that are available
and the provision of further hotel
accommodation is an important component
of the investment strategy
this planning application was first
submitted in june 2016.
the processing of the application has
taken a considerable amount of time
and i don't make any criticism of your
planning officers
because the reason has been relating to
making a foul drainage connection and
that's involved considerable
time consuming negotiations with seven
trent water
and the environment agency and it is now
accepted that
a main drainage connection can be made
itself
involving considerable costs and so
development of this scale
is all part of that strategy in terms of
justifying that expenditure
however on the 2nd of december 2020 the
county highway authority corps responded
with the district council
expressing the opinion that this large
hotel should be subject to
accumulative traffic assessment and the
applicant only became aware of that
request when the
consultation was posted on the portal on
the 10th of december
and so i make a an unusual request to
the committee uh this evening that
consideration of this application is
deferred
in order to enable the applicant to
address
the the transport issues that latterly
have been raised
it is an outline application and i think
a deferral would allow the applicant to
consider the other
issues raised in the offices report
and in such a deferral it seems to me
would be appropriate opportunity for the
applicant to provide an updated
master plan so that the issues that have
been raised by members being concerned
as to the overall picture
could also be presented back to your
authority at a later date for
determination as to whether
this particular proposal should be
permitted or denied consent
thank you chairman mr frampton thank you
very much for that we do have a question
for you from councillor parry that's it
hello good evening again mr frampton um
can i just can i can i ask um
obviously you you're now suddenly asking
us to
defer can i ask why you did why it was
decided not to withdraw the application
um the withdrawal of if you withdraw the
application you clearly
have to start again in terms of
updating a report because this is an
application was
submitted in 2016.
the the process would then delay the
determination coming back
for 13 weeks under the normal
time arrangement for considering a major
application
and it is considered that if a short
deferral
uh bearing in mind where we are with the
christmas period then this application
could come back to
this committee say in february of next
year which would be a
shorter period of time
lovely thank you very much i can't see
any further questions from our members
at this time
what i would say though if i may i was
going to say this after our next item
which obviously is again is the
dallas person polo club um you've made
reference to the uh
the need to or the desire to bring
forward a master plan
should we defer to this item tonight i
think it's really
important to help support us in our dis
our decision making but not just us also
uh
um the the planners within the council
uh if either yourself or the owners or
both
could engage fully with our portfolio
holder and indeed the two ward members
that are involved
with that master plan and of course the
parish councils so we're all aware that
will that will support us
in in understanding your plans for the
for the sites the next 10 15 years
so i would encourage you to do that
regardless of the decision that we make
on this
uh application this evening um
there being no other questions for you
at this point um
thank you once again uh if you want to
press r6 to mute yourself because we do
have you listed
once again to speak on the next item so
we will speak to you shortly
but thank you okay
uh let's now move to points of
clarification
members could you indicate in the chat
please if you have a question to our
officer forgive me i'm
a little slow my machine is gradually
reloading the meeting
chat here we go um counselor parry first
of all please
or if i jumped the gun maybe it's
councillor kendall
candle do you want to start us off thank
you
um it's not so much question given
what's just been said
i don't see why we shouldn't acquiesce
to the request of the applicant i think
they've asked if i'm happy to go to that
actually at this point
but there you go go ahead sorry
i think you're muted chairman
sorry um let's get the points
clarification done first
uh and i will come to you first in the
debate uh
to re-hear what you just said so does
anyone have a question
for our officer
that being the case counselor kendall
i'm going to assume that you are
proposing we prefer
that we just fed up marvelous thank you
very much on the basis of the
conversation we've just had
i'm going to second that um does anyone
else want to say anything at this point
in relation to the debate seeing lots of
no's good okay in that case let's move
to a vote
so the vote uh is to defer so that we
can get
more information uh pertaining to the
site
i'll go first councilworships4
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall four
councillor fleming cancer flaring for
councillor crumb stein
councillor curtis councillor curtis for
councillor dixon councillor dixon for
conservation
for anthem
councillor parry ford
marvelous thank you very much in that
case committee resolves to
defer application uh 1602 147
ful pending further information and
detailed master plan for the site
let's move to our next item which is
twenty zero one three six eight
f u l that is once again dallas burst
and polo grounds
uh eddie wrench is our presenting
officer eddie
when you're ready please thank you chair
i'll just get open the slide
okay this is our final application on
the dallas bursting site not tonight but
on the dallas person site
which is for the 100 camping pictures uh
shown here on the western edge
uh donated in blue is the use of the
land for up to 100 pitches for touring
caravans and camper vans including
engineering works
for internal roads and parking spaces
uh this is a site plan
of the site showing the various pitches
and some of the
landscaping works that will be done
throughout the site
this is a view over part of the field
so looking southwards from near to the
public right of way
sm 19.
this again is uh with the
proposed access road on the left hand
side with the
field or part of the field for the
camping on to the right hand side this
is looking back towards the polo grounds
in the distance
and this is one looking more westerly um
there is
significance or bonding and various
levels that i think has been
distributed in the area which would need
to be
leveled off over time if the application
came forward
and this is near to the public
right-of-way near the bascot road
chairman the recommendation
is to refuse for the
reasons on pages 66 and 67 of the agenda
uh updates again from long itchington
paris council on the master planning
issue
uh otherwise over to you chair thank you
eddie thank you very much uh we'll move
straight to our speakers once again no
parashar town council
uh listed on our list of speakers this
evening so we have
our first objector who is councillor
crump this time as our
adjacent wall member council crump thank
you for your patience welcome back again
three minutes 30 seconds when you're
ready so normally impatience when it's
in regards to me so i will be as patient
and brief as possible
um first i'd just like to say that
um talked about the applications this is
uh i've been doing with long ishington
parish council with
with the ward member i think the problem
with
what is this site is that the parish
council is
finally particularly difficult to
respond effectively to the
plethora of applications for
developments on the site that are
submitted on a regular basis and
as a statutory council t that is quite
difficult uh
you know quite difficult and sad to hear
so i do find that
that we do need to support our parish
councils and obviously parish councils
uh councillors are or volunteers some
have
really got a lot of expert knowledge so
i do sympathize with them so
i think we do need is a form of localism
to to consider these sorts sort of
things so that's just a general point
as regarding the application i think the
officer eddie has done an excellent
report here and
for the reasons mentioned in the report
are asking
the planning committee to refuse this
application thank you
that's the crap thank you very much
members do we have any questions for
cancer cramp at this point
lots of shaking heads no no no okay
cancer cramp thank you
very much we will move then to uh
mr frampton once again our applicant's
agent mr frampton if you press star in
six
do you want to mute yourself please
thank you you're back good man thank you
very much you've got three minutes 30
second warning
whenever you're ready thank you as i've
said the planning system
must be responsive to changing
socioeconomic circumstances
the health pandemic and the subsequently
induced economic crisis
will lead to changing patterns of
tourism whether by reason of financial
constraints on holidays
or a general unwillingness to travel to
destinations where large amounts of
people congregate
caravanning and the use of camping cars
is expected to become increasingly
popular for many
preferring to stay within the uk for
holidays potentially with more
short-term breaks
the amount of land on the approved
campsite has been reduced on account of
land taken by
hs2 for ecological works the approved
site no longer has the capacity to
accommodate touring caravans and camping
cars
the applicant hence proposes that the
touring caravans and camping cars can
use
five hectares of land on the western
side of the polar grounds
not involving any of the formal polo
pitches
for touring caravans and camping cars
the underlying role of policy sc cs 24
is to increase the role of tourism in
order to support the local economy
and provide the opportunity for local
communities to enjoy the benefits from
tourism expenditure
policy cs24 has a locational preference
for large-scale overnight accommodation
to be located within stratford
upon avon or main rural centers
with the important caveat wherever
possible
in my submission it is not realistic to
envisage this form of use being located
within the urban area of
stratford-upon-avon or southam
or any other of the rural centers there
is a clear locational synergy between
this use and the facilities available at
the polar grounds
including the sporting fixtures the
supply site provides extensive
infrastructure to support such a use
in view of the changing economic
circumstances it seems to me that the
district should welcome this proposal
which will bring new sources of tourism
revenue the cost
across the district and beyond in
respect to the traffic and parking
issues that are raised i say this
touring caravan sites do not typically
impact upon the operation of the highway
network
because tourists travel throughout the
day for arrival and departures
the development will not have an adverse
impact upon the operation of the highway
network
and in respect of touring caravan sites
the towing vehicle
typically is stationed along the caravan
there is
500 square meters there is ample space
for cars to be parked
alongside a caravan camping car
obviously involves no other vehicle
invite members to improve this
application which i consider to be
policy compliant
if members wish to consider the
cumulative impact then there is
an opportunity again for this
application to be deferred
and reported back at the same time as
the hotel application
thank you mr franklin
thank you very much once again members
do we have
any questions mr franklin at this point
not seeing a lot of activity at the
moment just give me another couple of
seconds if you want to type something
into the chat
nope okay uh thank you very much um
mr frampton uh thank you again for your
contributions this evening and your
patients as we work through the agenda
it is greatly appreciated um as i said
to
uh uh councillor walster previously
you're probably best served now to
continue to watch either on the live
stream
and uh or through our website uh
if you want to hang up your phone now
then that is no problem at all but thank
you again for your contribution and
patience
okay let's then move to questions to our
officer or points of clarification does
anyone
have a point of clarification councillor
dixon does council dixon
thank you chairman uh eddie um this
obviously
relates to a situation whereby they were
hoping to
put a number of pitches elsewhere to
land that has been lost
or otherwise acquired and what have you
um
and obviously we had the years was again
a replacement of
caravans and motorhomes etc just one
before we go into a debate as to whether
we either debate it or
take the opportunity to defer um could
you put up that one landscape plan which
showed the five the various parcels of
land please eddie and perhaps point out
where the land has been lost so that we
can see
and equally well um mr frampton
made reference to the fact that this was
five hectares i'm just wondering if the
previous site where he was hoping to use
was also five hectares
i'm afraid i don't know have the details
in terms of
land that's been lost in terms of extant
permissions
there is a permission uh within this
field
for uh camping and yurts
and mobile homes so that is part of an
extent permission
but that wouldn't be affected by this
application it might be affected by
other reasons for the applicant
they may have agreements with hs2 um but
that isn't a part of this site and
there's there's been no
discussion about uh uh restricting any
of the other permissions on site
so it in terms of this application i can
only assume that's the other permission
that
that's um being raised
thank you very much eddie could you the
previous slide i think it's the previous
slide uh to this one
has a line across it that shows us where
hs2 is likely to go
do you have a slide that shows that
that's right at the start yeah
you could show us that that will give us
some indication
as to what's being lost
there we go so that i think that's
probably
gonna help you in in understanding the
the land that may well be lost or
yeah it is tunneled that part
so but obviously hs2 has some issues
with uh
improving biodiversity around those
areas
so it wouldn't necessarily be on the
ground there wouldn't be a railway line
there it would be
tunneled but it might be but that's not
it doesn't form part of
this application no understood
okay thank you very much um there is no
one indicating in the chat that they
would like to have any further points
clarified so let's move
into the debate who would like to kick
us off please indicate in the chat if
you would like to start
see anyone ah councillor para right
fabulous castle
thank you chair um well along on the
basis of the other because they haven't
i would actually like to see this
application deferred and come back so
that we can see the whole master plan
and see how it all works together
it would also give us an opportunity for
the ward member
to give his comments um i appreciate
adam was unable to to join us this
evening and unless i've misunderstood
anything and he's not able to comment
he would be helpful as members of the
committee
to have a response from the ward member
when it is such a major site and he
knows
the area so much better um that
that i feel you know we've had five
major
applications some have been
retrospective and sadly
for um for various reasons we've got
no no element of guidance in terms of
what
what the ward member thinks and i
actually
you know we do rely on feedback
and comments from the ward member and on
the basis that we've deferred the
previous one
i would like to recommend we defer this
one so that we can at least
see the master plan and also have some
invaluable input from the ward member
who really knows this area
knows knows how it's going to
impact residents and actually knows the
site like the back of his hand
so i i wish to propose that we defer
this
thank you that's the parry thank you
very much had you not come in when you
did
i think i probably would have uh said
exactly the same thing
um in order for us to fully understand
the cumulative impact in particular
uh of the entire site i think it is uh
imperative that we now
uh see a master plan or at least the
agent and or the owner
engage with the council so we can see a
master plan so i fully support that and
will second your proposal
before we move to a vote councillor
dixon has indicated his desire to speak
so i shall ask him to come in first
councillor dixon thank you chairman the
only comment i would add is that uh
if the extent planning permission which
eddie showed um is to be
removed by the applicants such that this
land is intended as a replacement for
that uh
if that requires the applicant to make
that clear
to the planners then this opportunity to
defer will provide such an opportunity
thank you lovely thank you very much i
don't think we need to add any of that
to
the proposal that has been seconded by
me i can see cancer fleming has
indicated his support for the proposal
as well councillor fleming do you want
to speak to that or are you happy for us
to move to a vote
happy for us to move to a vote marvelous
thank you very much um okay in that case
we will
so the vote is to uh defer for the
reasons given i'll go first council for
richards four
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall four
councillor fleming cancer flaring four
councillor curtis councillor curtis four
councillor dickson councillor dixon four
councillor henshaw seraphin council
hencher serving four
clean councillor pari councillor
councillor paris
iv four unanimous chairman
wellness thank you very much ann uh in
that case committee resolves to
defer application twenty zero one three
six eight ful dallas burst and holograms
in southern
for the reasons given thank you very
much um
moving now to our final item of the
evening can i just confirm that we do
have our speaker
in the lobby or in the meeting for this
item
i don't think he's joined yet chairman i
think that he was probably waiting to
hear the end of the last one and then
he'll be dialing in
okay um justin's going to give him a
call just to ensure but he did say to me
that he was going to watch it
and that he would be dialing in as it
was wrapping up
lovely i proposed we crack on um and
while we're doing that if
uh we could try and dial him in and and
bring in the speaker uh before we get to
that stage
that would be great so um the
application is twenty zero
two six eight four f u l
our presenting officer is at victoria
captain victoria whenever you are ready
over to you perfect thank you chair can
everyone
um see the slides and can everyone hear
me okay certainly can
you right i'll make a start then um so
this application is for detached
outbuilding serving as ancillary
accommodation
within the garden of ye oldbarn the
application site is identified by the
black dot in the village of sanborn
you can see that the site of the
application dwelling is outlined with a
red line
in terms of constraints ye old barn is a
grade two listed building
and you can see other listed buildings
in the area which are also colored in
red
the purple line indicates the extent of
the sanborn conservation area
now the green hash line shows position
of a public right of way
which joins the application site along
the southern boundary and this
path leads to open countryside beyond
the east of the site
now the site is also within the green
belt as well as the arden special
landscape area
so to the left is the existing site plan
which shows the position of the main
house
as well as the previously approved
garage block which was later converted
into an annex and linked to the property
you can see that the position of the
static caravan and storage container
which are proposed to be removed
the site benefits from extant permission
for a detached garage block
which i will go into a bit more detail
later
so the proposed plan to the right shows
the position of the new ancillary
accommodation
so the accommodation would support a
bedroom bathroom lounge and dining area
as well as a storage room
as shown on the proposed elevations the
design would be single story with a dual
pitch roof
in terms of materials the building would
be clad in timber
the outbuilding would measure
approximately 8.1 meters in length
by 5.1 meters in width with a height of
4.5 meters approximately
given that the property is in the green
belt and is over five meters from the
main
dwelling there is a full back position
in the form of an extant permission for
a detached garage
this was approved in 2004 and as part of
this permission an existing nissan hut
was removed
which is no longer on the site
so this side shows the approved plans in
2004 for the garage
which is in a similar position to the
proposed ancillary accommodation under
consideration
externally the design included timber
weatherboarding with a single
garage door in terms of in terms of the
size the x-stand permission would be
roughly one meter smaller in length and
width
and approximately 200 millimeters
smaller in height than the proposed
development
this side shows a photo of the main
house to the left with the mobile home
adjacent as you enter the site and to
the right
there is the proposed sighting of the
new garage and that's the existing
storage container in situ so
this side shows both the caravan and
storage container in greater detail
which are proposed to be removed
neither the caravan nor the storage
container benefit from consent
so the first image on the left is taken
from outside of the site
showing the position of the proposed
outbuilding out there
and here is the public right-of-way and
the image on the right is taken from the
green where you can see the site here
so on the whole officers are
recommending refusal of this application
based on the reasons outlined in the
officer report
we've received one update from the agent
confirming that the outbuilding would be
finished in timber boarding as listed on
the update sheet
so that concludes my presentation and
thank you chair
victoria that was great thank you very
much very eloquently delivered
we are still waiting for our speaker i
believe so
we're just gonna adjourn for two minutes
while we try and call our speaker
in so if we could please adjourn for two
minutes while we do that
please make sure your microphones are
muted during this adjournment
as the meeting is still live
okay i believe we have our speaker here
and ready to go
so our speaker is the agent for the
application uh mr gary
moss mr moss can you hear me okay yeah
apologies i've um major problems i don't
quite know why my phone wasn't working
so apologies
to you members and everyone um
you're not the first to get technical
difficulties and you might you won't be
the last
but you're here and that's the important
thing you have three minutes
we'll give you a 30 second warning
whenever you're ready please do fire
away
okay okay hello members
um obviously many
of you will recall this item being
before you
last time a few months back the
applicant has undertaken quite
significant changes in terms of
changing the accommodation and the size
and design of the building
picking up on the previous concerns
raised by the planning case officer
and also the conservation officer
members will see from the report that
the conservation officer
has now withdrawn their objections to
scheme
the only issue before you is that of one
of
its impact on the green belt we
disagree with the case officer's
assessment that this
can't be considered as an extension we
appreciate the policy
requires our buildings to be within five
meters
of the main house to be considered as
such and hence
appropriate developments but at 6.5
meters away
and also on the site of an extent
planning permission for an existing
garage
or be it smaller than this being
proposed
we feel that that in itself is
justification for the location
my client is well established within the
village
they are currently residing in a caravan
on site whilst their parents live in the
main house
this building will enable them to
effectively swap over
with my clients becoming the main
occupiers in the main house
and their parents occupying the annex
accommodation
there will be benefits in terms of
removing of the caravan
from the site itself not particularly
visually enhancing
of the landscape rural landscape or the
greenbelt
and also the steel container which
through the passage of time has been on
site for in excess of ten years
these two factors we feel would
easily outweigh the harm to the
greenbelt
as set out by the planning case officer
through the slight enlargement over that
of the extent
garage situation the application has
full support of the parish council
there are no local objections and in
this case we would ask members to
consider the development as
appropriate in the green belt addressing
all the previous concerns
raised by the officer if
failing that there are certainly very
special circumstances
in particular that of the fallback
position and the client's needs
together with the improvement to the
green belt that we would hope
members would enable them to grant
planning permission for this development
and and in this case overturn their
officers
recommendation thank you very much for
your time
you very much 30 seconds before your
time was up so well done mr moss thank
you very much
uh we do have some questions for you if
you if you could bear with us so first
of all councillor dixon please
thank you chairman uh mr moss um
obviously you're
like this to be considered as an
extension to the property
rather than as a new building in the
green belt
uh one of the elements that we look at
when considering extensions
is the increase in volume over the
original building
now obviously as a listed building i'm
assuming it was there before 1948.
um have you uh by any chance a volume
calculation as to
what the property volume was the
original
prior to any extensions and what it
would be if this was now granted
uh i haven't done any volume
calculations in respect to the original
uh dwelling i can confirm that yes
the the dwelling um is
uh way before 1948
there was a garage which was converted
i think originally into annex
accommodation and then later has been
encompassed within the main house so the
property has
been extended um but
in the argument that we are really
putting forward it's really the extent
garage permission
that remains in situ on site which we're
looking to effectively replace
we accept it is larger but not
disproportionately larger than that
of the main house as standing so i don't
have any exact volume calculations for
you
um but we would consider it would still
fall within
um a reasonable extension and one that
is not disproportionate to that of the
original
building as stood and the barns prior to
1948.
thank you very much thank you thank you
both
uh council parents
thank you chair good evening mr moss i
just wonder
a whether you can just re-emphasize the
special
circumstances um i know you sort of said
a lot of things in your presentation but
if you could just
hone in on those for me and also i just
i was going to ask have you had any
dialogue
with the ward member because um there's
no response
on this particular on this occasion um
from from the ward member thank you mr
moss
on the second point first of all um i've
had no direct communications
with the ward member we've had
discussions
and have been heavily involved with the
parish council
and obviously they've actively supported
the scheme
but no nothing with the ward member
in terms of very special circumstances
well
first of all i would argue that actually
the development should be considered
appropriate the reason the case officer
has considered it not to be appropriate
is obviously the
fact that it's 6.5 meters away
from the dwelling rather than the five
meter as
required by the development management
considerations in support of policy cs10
but that aside we feel that because of
the extant
garage permission in situ i mean that
garage in itself would not
under current guidance be suitable for
meeting the requirements of a car
um so even if we were to replace that
garage the likelihood is we'd be looking
for a building that is bigger
not dissimilar to the annex we've put
forward
we have obviously undertaken design
changes to the building compared to that
previously
considered by members the scheme would
also remove
an unsightly caravan now appreciate that
caravan is there without the benefit of
planning permission
but it provides the necessary
accommodation that my clients are
looking for
the removal of that ultimately or
retention of that we feel would be
far greater an adverse impact on the
green belt
more importantly the steel container
which is
highly prominent adjacent to the public
footpath
is lawful for the passage of time my
clients
do use that as sort of storage as part
of their business but they are happy to
remove that container from the green
belt in order to
provide enhancement and offset the
slightly
increase of this annex building to that
of the extent garage
there is also the sort of social element
that
my clients parents are looking to
downsize they are well respected members
of the community have lived there
many years and this proposal would
enable them to remain
in the village where they have friends
family connections
but obviously allow my clients
their son and daughter and young
children to move into the main house so
cumulatively we would consider those to
be the very special circumstances in
this case
lovely thank you very much both of you
there are
no other comments or requirements for
questions uh from members to you
in our meeting chat mr moss so i think
uh that's it for now thank you
very much again for your uh your you
joining us this evening
um and for your contribution again you'd
be best served now to watch continue
watching on either on the live feed
through our website on youtube
fantastic thank you very much thank you
very much okay
cheers bye okay
and let's move now two points
clarification for our officers
would anyone like something clarified
please indicate in the chat if you do
while we're waiting for people to type
um i'm gonna ask a question if i may
uh victoria on page 76 uh
you have under historic environment
you've pointed out the fact that the
garage was approved on the site
and therefore the principle for
development
at this location has already been
established
is it safe for me to assume that given
that comment
the difference between the five meters
and the 6.5 meters that our agent has
referred to
has not really come into the equation
the principle is fine it's the
size of the dwelling sorry the signs of
the building
that you have particular issue with is
that fair
so so there's the there's
extant permission for a building in that
location the five meter rule hasn't come
into account
on that element um i can give you
further information if you wish
um as to why we've considered that being
over 6.5 meters away
isn't considered as a as an extension um
but there is extra permission within
that location
um which is which is where that's come
from
is that clear you answered my question
in the first couple of sentences you
said so thank you that's that's ideal
thank you
um casa perry has a question for you as
well please
thanks very much chan and thank you
victoria for your
um excellent presentation um
the application that was
refused back in september obviously
we've got
no response from the ward member
i would just find it helpful i
appreciate
it maybe that you you can't answer this
because we're discussing this
application
but it it it would be helpful to know
um what the whether the ward member was
in support of
of the application that was refused back
in september
i don't have this information to happen
if you can have a look
it is important that members
consider this application on its merits
uh and in accordance with your
development plan and not in accordance
with the imagined wishes of a member who
isn't here i'm sorry chair
that's inappropriate direction to go i
am happy with that comment and i i think
i'm inclined to agree with you as well
let's move uh move on from it um
i can't see any further points of
clarification in the meeting chat so i'm
going to assume we can move straight to
the debate
who would like to kick us off in the
debate
counselor dixon please
thank you chairman uh i think i heard
this correct
um basically they're looking at a
situation whereby there's an extent
permission for a garage
and i think the garage was granted
permission if i'm right
to replace a mizzen hut now
i'll make the assumption that the mizzen
hut was considerably smaller than the
garage
the annex that is now requested is
significantly larger
than the garage so we're going up slowly
by surely
but we also heard from mr moss that the
garage that's got permission
would be too small to act as a garage
down so if it's too small to act as a
garage it's not a very good fallback
position
and therefore from my point of view i
think this one is uh
a new building it's not an extension in
the green belt
and i know i had uh strong feelings
about a greenhouse which we were
discussing at the previous committee
meeting
uh but essentially i think this one is
significantly uh worse than that
and the idea that there's a container on
there without permission
etc i feel that this ought to be refused
and i would
propose that we accept the officer's
recommendation of refusal
lovely thank you very much councillor
dixon councillor henshaw serafin is next
please
thank you chair as adjacent board member
i've walked down this footpath
over the years many a time and
i would feel that this application would
enhance the area
because it was never any good looking
towards your left
as you walk down this footpath so i
wouldn't have any objections with this
application at all
thank you it would enhance the area
thank you councillor councillor curtis
next please
thank you chair um yes
i don't know the area but given that
this development would see the removal
of what looks like a pretty aging
caravan
um really tidying up the site getting
rid of the container
and considering some of the things that
we just have been approving
um also this application has the support
from the parish council i think we
should as a committee be listening to
what the
local councils as was said earlier on
and i
i would support this application
i'd like to find a way of doing that i
will leave you to come up with your way
of doing that
we do have a proposal to uh refuse
in line with the officer's
recommendation i'm inclined to agree
with councillor dixon on that
um on the basis that uh a as we've heard
there is an extent permission
for a garage um and i will find the
sizing in just a moment i believe it was
seven meters by four point two by and
four point two five high now i find it
hard to believe that a car
can't fit in a seven by four meter
property or building
um so to suggest it was no is it is no
longer fit for purpose
i i'm quite surprised by notwithstanding
that um as we said the principle of
development
has already been established by virtue
of the that previous consent
um but we are talking about a
substantially larger building and that
is what i have an issue with
um i don't think we can offset in my
opinion i don't think we can offset
the removal of two uh
buildings is probably the wrong word a
static caravan and
um a uh container that don't have
benefit of planning permission they
frankly they shouldn't be there anyway
so it can't be used in my opinion in the
an
asset against uh greenback policy
i can't see any reason why we would
grant this um i can't see any
sound reasoning unless certainly i don't
see any special circumstances or very
special circumstances
that would allow me to go against green
belt policy so i am going to second
cancel dixon's proposal
i can't see anyone else in the meeting
chats making any
uh suggestion they want to speak i'm
going to give you 30 seconds if you want
to come back with any further
points otherwise we'll move to a vote
and given i see very little movement on
my screen
i'm going to assume that that's a no
counselor henry's stereophone has come
in so council hunter seraphim
thank you chair um as these people live
in this mobile home
that they want to get rid of surely this
would be an
asset for them to live in in this new
application
um it would blend in you can't see it
from the main road
at all the only time you would see it if
you walk down
the public footpath and there's no
objections in the village
and it's supported by the parish council
so that should weigh in
quite a bit as far as i'm concerned
thank you
okay thank you guys fair comment i
i'm afraid it doesn't change my mind but
it may have changed at the members minds
um there being no one else indicating
they wish to uh
to speak at this point well let's move
to a vote um the proposal is to refuse
in line with the officers recommendation
i will start us off councillor richards
four thank you councillor kendall
councillor curtis councillor curtis
against
councillor dickson councillor dixon four
councillor hensha seraphin ancelandra
serving again
councillor parry councillor parry four
thank you one two three four five four
two against one abstention chairman
and thank you very much uh committee
therefore resolves to
refuse application twenty zero two six
eight four f
u l ye old barn of the green in
sanborn members that concludes
our uh meeting for this evening and in
fact for this year
uh we won't see you again until the 6th
of january which is when our next
committee meeting is so it leaves me to
say thank you to you all
and in particular to our officers and
those that have contributed to us this
evening and indeed of watch this evening
merry christmas to all of you have a
fabulous time
and a very happy new year let's hope
it's a better one than 2020
we'll close the meeting there thanks
very much